hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and let me ask you
a question why would a master swordsman
who dedicated his entire life to being a
demon slayer betrayed the demon slayer
core in order to become the second most
powerful demon in the world second only
to muzon himself why would someone who
had a close personal connection to the
strongest demon slayer in history
yorichi tsugikuni and someone who
abandoned his own family just to focus
full time on becoming a demon player one
day decide to accept a deal with the
devil turn against his own comrades and
cut them down on muzon's orders in this
video i will reveal the dark truth about
the biggest and most dangerous traitor
in the history of the demon slayer core
upper moon one kokushibo if you guys
enjoy our demonstr content and you want
us to keep it going just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps with that youtube
algorithm and if you're looking for a
completely free but important way of
supporting the channel directly don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it might seem like a small
unimportant thing but here on youtube
subscribing matters a lot finally this
video will contain demon slayer manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned kokushibo was born
nearly 500 years ago and kokushibo was
not his birth name instead his birth
name was michikatsu tsugikuni and he
wasn't born alone michikatsu had a
younger twin brother and his name was
yorichi togikuni the same yurichi who
would one day become the strongest demon
slayer of all time and the original
breath of the sun user michikatsu and
yurichi came from a powerful samurai
family and at this time during the
sengoku period twins were considered to
be a bad omen that's because the fact
that they were born at practically the
same time could result in a succession
dispute down the line on top of that
yorichi was born with a strange
birthmark on his face and so their
father decided that the best thing to do
would be to simply get rid of little
yurichi that would eliminate any
potential succession battles in the
future and it would also appease
everyone who had superstitious fears
about yurichi's birthmark however
michikatsu and yorichi's mother refused
to let this happen and she became so
angry and aggressive that her husband
had to agree to spare yorichi's life
instead of eliminating the younger twin
the family would raise him until he
reached the age of 10 and then they
would send him to a temple where he
would become a monk since monks must
renounce all of their worldly
possessions yorichi will have no claim
to the family's property and status and
so michikatsu could seamlessly succeed
his father as the head of the family
after this decision was made the two
brothers had a completely different
upbringing michikatsu was groomed to
become the head of the family and so he
had superior living quarters fancier
clothes better food better education and
so on and while michikatsu was busy
preparing himself to one day succeed his
father yorichi became extremely attached
to their mother and he would always be
clinging to her left side michikatsu
pitied his little brother so he would
often sneak into his brother's little
room in order to play with him
michikatsu wasn't able to give yorichi
any of his possessions because their
father would notice and become angry so
michikatsu gave his brother a wooden
flute that he himself had made yorichi
was an unusual child he never smiled not
even as a baby and he didn't speak until
the age of seven everyone thought that
maybe he was deaf and so he would never
be able to speak properly but michigan
learned that his brother wasn't deaf one
day when he was doing sword practice in
the garden yorichi was standing silently
behind michikatsu and watching him but
then suddenly he actually said something
he said my brother is your dream to
become the strongest samurai in the
nation michikatsu was so shocked to hear
his brother speaking for the first time
that he gasped and dropped his wooden
training sword yorichi then said that he
also wanted to become a samurai but
michikatsu knew that when he turned 10
yurichi would be sent to a temple he was
destined to become a monk not a samurai
then michikatsu saw his brother smile
for the first time and it was such a
strange sight that it actually disturbed
him knowing that yurichi was going to be
sent to a temple and also knowing that
yurichi was a mama's boy who constantly
clung to their mother michikatsu didn't
take yurichi's words about becoming a
samurai very seriously and yet after
that brief conversation yorichi started
hanging around his brother and the
family's swordsmanship instructor during
their swordsmanship training and he
expressed the desire to learn the way of
the sword the instructor was their
father's vassal and he didn't see any
harm in letting yurichi practice with
them so he gave him a wooden practice
sword and that is when it happened after
only a few words of basic instruction
the instructor asked yorichi to try and
hit him michikatsu wasn't expecting much
from this since he himself had never
succeeded in landing a single hit on
their instructor no matter how hard he
tried but the seven-year-old yorici
managed to land four strong blows on
their instructor in the blink of an eye
and these hits were so strong that they
knocked the instructor out yurichi's
blows didn't break any bones or cause
any permanent injuries but they left
massive lumps on the instructor's body
in the places where the wooden sword had
hit after this incident yorichi stopped
saying that he wanted to be a samurai he
hated the feeling of hitting someone and
he didn't want anything to do with that
type of life but michikatsu wanted to
know the secret behind yorichi's
strength so he kept pushing him to
explain how he became so strong that's
when we learned that even as a kid
yorichi could see into the transparent
world so he could anticipate his
opponent's movements based on the
positions of their bones the
contractions of their muscles and the
flow of their blood yorichi was also
born with exceptional strength and speed
and that is when michigatu came to a
startling conclusion all this time he
had pitied his younger brother but the
truth was that yorichi was actually far
superior to him now michikatsu worked
hard and he had talent so he definitely
got stronger but his progress was
negligible compared to the overpowering
natural talents of yorichi and even
though yorici wasn't interested in the
samurai life anymore after the
instructor told their father about
yurichi's incredible talent the father
suddenly changed his mind he now wanted
yorichi to take over as the head of the
family instead of michikatsu and
michikatsu was now forced to sleep in
that small isolated room where yorichi
had slept all this time worse yet
michikatsu was now to be sent to the
temple when he turned 10 instead of
yurichi which meant that michikatsu's
lifelong dream of becoming a samurai
would never come true but then one night
while michikatsu was lying in bed
yorichi came to him and told them that
their mother had died michikatsu was
shocked by this and he thought the death
must have been very sudden but yorichi
merely told them to ask her servant
about the details because he will now be
departing for the temple michikatsu is
confused by this since yurichi was no
longer being forced to go to the temple
but yurichi says that he just wanted to
say goodbye yorichi also said that he
will bring the wooden flute that
michikatsu had made for him so that he
could feel close to his older brother
wherever he goes michikotsu thought that
flute was a poorly made piece of junk
that couldn't even produce sounds
properly and he was surprised to see
orichi safeguarding it inside a cloth
and acting like it was some sort of
treasure yorichi then left for the
temple and michikatsu proceeded to read
his mother's journal as he read the
journal he learned that yorichi had
sensed that their father was planning to
designate him as the heir instead of
michikatsu so he left for the temple
earlier than expected that way their
father would have no choice but to stick
to the original plan and allow michika
to succeed him as the head of the family
michikatsu also realized that his mother
had been suffering from an illness for
years and that yurichi had sensed it
this illness affected the left side of
their mother's body so when yorichi was
clinging to that side he wasn't really
clinging instead he was supporting her
because her body had been weakened from
the illness and in that moment as he
realized that yorichi was so much more
observant and talented and compassionate
than him michikatsu began to burn with
jealousy it was like yorichi was perfect
in every way superior in every way and
in that moment michikatsu hated his own
brother from the bottom of his heart
because he was so profoundly jealous of
yorichi's genius the irony here is that
when yurichi was treated as the black
sheep of the family michikatsu felt
sorry for him and he tried to help him
but it is clear that in his own mind
michikatsu had also accepted the idea
that he was superior to yorichi when the
tables turned and yorichi was shown to
be far more impressive than his brother
in practically every way michikatsu's
ego couldn't handle it and he began
wishing that his brother had never been
born because his very existence defied
the laws of nature nevertheless
michikatsu's jealousy subsided after
yurichi disappeared from his life
although their father tried to bring
yurichi back from the temple yorichi had
disappeared without a trace and no one
could find him anywhere and so
michikachu's father had no choice but to
go back to the original plan michikatsu
was the heir apparent again and as 10
years passed he settled down and started
a family his days were tranquil and
boring and he lived a calm and
comfortable life but then one day a
demon attacked michikatsu and his men in
the forest the demon killed michikaw's
men and was about to kill him as well
when an adult yorichi showed up and took
the demon down in an instant the moment
that michikatsu saw his brother again he
could tell right away that yorichi had
mastered the sword and that he was an
incredible warrior michikatsu's serenity
was destroyed and he began to burn with
jealousy yet again yorichi was
unbelievably strong and he had an
impeccable character and michikatsu
decided that he would do anything to
become as strong and as skilled with a
sword as his brother so michikatsu
abandoned his family and he dedicated
his entire life to becoming a demon
slayer which was the same path that
yorichi had chosen michikatsu trained
directly under yurichi and he learned
breathing techniques directly from his
brother
but none of the demon slayers michikatsu
included were able to match yorichi's
power they simply could not replicate
the breathing style that he used the
breath of the sun so yorici changed the
breathing technique slightly as he
taught them to different individuals in
order to make it possible for them to
actually learn and master these
techniques that is how all the many
derivatives of sun breathing emerged and
one of those derivatives was
michikatsu's own moon breathing
eventually michikatsu manifested a
demonstrator mark identical to the one
that his twin brother was born with and
overall michikatsu became an extremely
strong swordsman and a top tier demon
slayer but despite his clearly
impressive strength he still couldn't
measure up to yorichi no matter how hard
he trained and no matter how much of his
life he dedicated to getting stronger
michikatsu could never learn sun
breathing and he could never compare to
the godlike skill and talent of his
brother to make things worse all the
demon players who managed to manifest
the demon sire mark began to die off
after reaching the age of 25 the demon
slayer mark bestowed the slayer with
more power but in exchange it
drastically shortened his lifespan
michikatsu realized that he was going to
die without ever even coming close to
achieving his dream of becoming the
strongest samurai and surpassing his
brother and that is when the notorious
demon king muzan approached him with a
proposal muzan told michikatsu that if
he became a demon he could live forever
and he wouldn't have to worry about
dying at the age of 25. he would have a
much stronger body and he would have all
of eternity to keep getting stronger
until his strength finally surpassed
even yorichi despite dedicating his
entire life to being a demon slayer and
destroying demons michikatsu's jealousy
and ego got the best of him he made a
deal with the devil he agreed to consume
muzan's blood and become a demon in
exchange for eternal life and superhuman
power afterwards michikatsu tsugikuni
became kokushibo and he turned against
his own demon slayer comrades together
with muzon he cut down the very demon
slayers that he had once called his
brethren so that no one would ever get
in the way of his and muzon's plans but
even after 60 years of being a demon
kokushibo still wasn't able to surpass
yorichi the two brothers would come face
to face again when yorichi was already
in his mid-80s naturally yorichi did not
die at the age of 25 despite having the
demon slayer mark which again emphasized
the fact that yorici was special and
more gifted than his brother being a
demon kokushiba didn't age and so he was
still at peak strength meanwhile yurichi
was a frail old man who inhabited a weak
human body instead of an immortal demon
body and yet even after six decades
yorichi was still stronger than
kokushibo his technique was so flawless
and godlike that he defeated the demon
kokushibo despite being an octogenarian
however yorichi died of old age before
he had the chance to strike the
finishing blow against kokushibo and so
kokushiba survived the battle but he was
forced to live another 400 years with
the knowledge that even as an old man
yurichi was still stronger than him to
make things worse when kokushibo cut
down yorichi's lifeless body he found
that small wooden flute that he had made
for his brother back when they were
children despite the fact that kokushibo
had betrayed the demonstr and despite
the fact that he became a ruthless demon
yorichi still carried that stupid crappy
flute that his twin brother gave him all
those years ago so not only was yorichi
stronger than kokushibo even in his 80s
but he still remained a man of flawless
character and endless compassion until
the very end as for kokushiba himself he
remained conflicted he was conflicted
between his love for his brother on the
one hand and his burning jealousy of him
on the other and he was also conflicted
between his lifelong desire to be an
honorable samurai warrior and the
reality of having become a demonic
monster these inner conflicts would
finally boil over during kokushiba's
final battle against muichiro genya
sanemi and gyome inside the infinity
castle the first opponent that kokushiba
encounters is the mist hashira muichiro
muichiro is immediately intimidated by
kokushibo's overpowering aura but
kokushiba's actual behavior is not what
you would expect from some blood thirsty
demon kokushibo is calm dignified and
polite and even asks for his opponent's
name before the battle begins once the
hashira introduces himself as muichiro
tokito kokushibo gives him his own human
name michikatsu
kuni kokushibo can sense that muichiro
is actually a descendant of one of the
children that he had left behind back
when he abandoned his family in order to
become a demon slayer the tsugikuni
family name must have died out over time
but muichiro was still a direct blood
descendant of kokushibo this is a
surprise to muichiro but it doesn't
change anything in terms of his own
goals and principles he steals his
nerves and attacks kokushibo with his
missed breathing techniques as muichiro
attempts to land a hit on kokushiba he
keeps missing over and over again but
kokushiba is still impressed with the
strength skill and courage of his
descendant especially since muichiro is
still only 14 years old kokushiba
decides that muichiro has earned his
respect and so he finally draws his
sword because not doing so would be
considered disrespectful towards his
opponent again notice that kokushibo
continues to cling to strict samurai
etiquette despite being a demon which
tells us that kokushibo has not given up
on his humanity at least not fully if
you pay close attention during his fight
you will also notice that kokushibo
doesn't like sustaining the kinds of
injuries that would kill a human even
though he clearly possesses demonic
regeneration he doesn't like having to
use it it's almost as if he considers
resorting to regeneration to be shameful
because if he had allowed himself to be
injured in that way as a human he would
have died as soon as kokushibo draws his
sword and reveals his moon breathing
technique muichiro is hit and loses his
hand but the young hashira is unfazed by
this he just uses his shirt to make a
tourniquet and continues to fight with
his other hand kokushibo is greatly
impressed by muijiro but more than just
being impressed by the actions of some
random stranger kokushibo is also proud
of his descendant he believes that
killing muichiro who is such a talented
warrior would be a shame and he decides
to ask muzan to turn muichiro into a
demon this is all important stuff
because you don't see someone like muzon
worrying about codes of honor samurai
etiquette or descendants muzon is
willing to do literally anything to stay
alive and satisfy his own desires and
all moral codes values and principles
are nothing to him so there is a stark
difference between kokushibo and muzon
in this regard kokushibo then pins
muichiro down to a pillar by piercing
him through the chest with his own sword
having immobilized his descendant
kokushibo plans to summon muzon and turn
muichiro into a demon however kokushibo
has to postpone this plan because he is
soon attacked by other demon slayers
first genya arrives and kokushibo takes
care of him pretty easily but then
sanemi and gyome also join the battle
and kokushiba is forced to turn his
attention to fighting the two hashida
muichiro uses the fact that kokushiba is
busy fighting gyome and sanemi to pull
the sword that had been pinning him to
the pillar from his own chest with his
own bare hands we can only imagine the
kind of pain that this caused him and
the insane amount of strength and
courage that was required for muichiro
to pull this off
say what you will about kokushi was
warped samurai values but he was
certainly right to be impressed by
muichiro at this point muichiro already
knows that he will almost certainly die
from blood loss as a result of the
injuries that he has already suffered
but he is determined to make a real
impact on the outcome of the battle
before he dies he jumps into the thick
of the battle and saves sanemy from one
of kokushiba's attacks and then
determined to help while he is still
able to move muichiro launches an
assault on kokushibo while kokushibu is
distracted by attacks from gyome and
tsunemi muichiro manages to move close
enough to pierce kokushibo's torso with
his sword muichiro loses one of his legs
during this approach but that doesn't
matter to him he is willing to make the
ultimate sacrifice in order to win this
battle as the epic battle rages muichiro
is determined to protect gyome and
tsunemi so that they will survive and be
able to continue to fight in the battle
against muzon he is so determined to
help defeat kokushiba before he dies
that his nichiren blade suddenly turns
red and this causes such pain to
kokushibo that he is unable to move
don't forget that red nichiren blades
can burn demons on a cellular level
which drastically reduces their ability
to regenerate a dying genya then manages
to use his blood demon art to keep
kokushibo in place long enough for
sunemi and gyome to take off his head
but even the loss of his head isn't
enough to take down a demon of
kokushibo's caliber as the demon slayers
look on in shock upper moon 1 is able to
regenerate even his head
but this second head looks nothing like
a human head it is a monstrous demonic
head and when kokushibo catches a
glimpse of his own face he is stunned
and disgusted and that is when the inner
conflict between kokushiba's deeply held
samurai values and the reality of being
a demon finally come to a head
ever since he was a child kokushiba
wanted to become the strongest samurai
in the world but after many years of
trying his best he eventually realized
that he could never surpass his
incredibly talented twin brother yorichi
yorichi had almost supernatural godlike
talent that simply could not be
surpassed
and so despite the fact that kokushiba
was an incredibly strong swordsman back
when he was human perhaps even the
second strongest swordsman in the world
after yurichi he was never quite good
enough to compete with his brother all
his training and dedication certainly
bore fruit and he became an unbelievable
warrior but there was just no way for
him to ever compare to yurichi kokushiba
tried everything to catch up to his
brother he abandoned his family he
betrayed his comrades and he gave up his
very humanity to surpass his brother and
to avoid defeat but in the end even a
deal with the devil himself didn't allow
him to achieve his dream not only did he
still fail to defeat yurichi but he also
failed to fulfill his initial dream the
one he had before becoming jealous of
his brother the dream of becoming the
strongest samurai upon seeing his
reflection kokushiba realized that even
if he had succeeded in becoming stronger
than yurichi once he became a demon he
would still not be the strongest samurai
that is because asamura lives by a code
of honor a samurai has values that he
would never abandon and a samurai would
rather die than live dishonorably a true
samurai would never willingly choose to
become a demon just to avoid accepting
defeat a true samurai would never devour
innocent people just to get stronger and
a true samurai doesn't have the face and
body of a monster kokushibo can't
believe that he allowed his fear of
defeat to turn him into an inhuman
creature kokushiba's internal conflicts
reach a boiling point he experiences a
severe crisis of conscience and his body
begins to break apart in the place where
muichiro had stabbed him with his red
blade kokushibo is then finished off by
gyome and sanemi and then after nearly
500 years of life upper mu 1 kokushibo
is destroyed genya and muichiro both die
from the wounds they suffered in the
battle against kokushibo but sanemy and
gyomay live long enough to fight in the
final battle against muzon unlike muzon
who completely abandoned his humanity in
the pursuit of power and immortality
kokushibo could never fully give up on
his human side despite making a deal
with the devil and despite betraying and
cutting down his own comrades he still
held on to his humanity he still saw
himself as a samurai who followed a code
of honor and proper etiquette he still
felt an attachment to his family which
is why he was so proud of muichiro and
he still felt a deep connection to his
brother yorichi even though a part of
him hated yurichi due to jealousy a part
of him still loved his brother and we
see proof of that when kokushiba's body
finally disintegrates and all that's
left is his clothing and the broken
flute that he had made for his brother
all those centuries ago kokushibo had
held on to that flute for literally
centuries just like he had held on to at
least some fragment of his humanity this
is why i love kokushibo as a character
yes he is incredibly strong and badass
yes he has a great design but he is also
a deeply flawed and in some ways
hypocritical character and in that sense
he is a deeply human character despite
being an overpowered demon who was
supposed to have abandoned his humanity
it is quite likely that even the team up
of three different hashira and genya
would not have been successful in taking
kukushibo down if he wasn't also faced
with a massive crisis of conscience at
the same time if kokushibo had been a
completely amoral sociopath like muzon
or doma he likely would have won the
fight against the demon slayers and
muzad would never have been defeated but
interestingly enough kokushibo was so
shocked by his own lack of humanity that
he couldn't keep fighting and so
ironically what was left of his humanity
was the very thing that ultimately led
to his defeat his defeat itself proved
that in the end kokushibo was still
human at least to some extent
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
definitely let me know what you think of
kokushiba's character down in the
comments below if you're looking for a
video to watch next check out my
extensive breakdown of every upper demon
moon's death i will link it in the
description be sure to leave a quick
like and comment if you want to support
this video in that treacherous youtube
algorithm and if you're new here or you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
huge favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications it
seems like a small and unimportant thing
but actually subscribing really helps
out a lot on youtube you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys